Rosins Restaurants gibt es seit 2009 146
Episoden in 16 Staffeln und die ganze
Zeit hat Frank Rosin nur ein Ziel
Gastronomen zu helfen sie zu retten sie
zu neuem Erfolg zu bringen und aus dem
Schlammassel zu helfen bei Wikipedia
steht allerdings dass nur 36 % der in
der Sendung gezeigten Betriebe heute
noch in der Form existieren was für mich
die Frage aufwirft wie geht es den
Geretteten Restaurants heute Wochen
Monate vielleicht Jahre nach der
Veröffentlichung deshalb habe ich mir
ein Restaurant rausgesucht das von Frank
Rosinen gerettet wurde genau genommen
ist es ein Imbiss und zwar Nickis Imbiss
und Nikis Imbiss liegt in waren in
Belgien direkt an der Grenze zu
Deutschland und ist mit sage und
schreibe 4,5 Sternen bewertet das ist
wirklich krass wenn man sich vorstellt
dass Nicki Frank Rosin zur Hilfe gerufen
hat weil er nicht mehr wusste wie es
weitergeht und dementsprechend auch mit
seinem Laden am Ende war sind 4,5 Sterne
eine stolze Bestandsaufnahme viele von
euch werden bestimmt die Folge gesehen
haben spätestens wenn ich hier durch die
Bilder scrolle wisst ihr auf jeden Fall
Bescheid es sieht wirklich schön aus
muss man auch sagen an der Stelle also
not bad wie das für eine Frittenbude
üblich ist gibt es Pommes gibt es
frittierte Snacks aber eben auch
hausgemachte Burger und andere
Spezialitäten gehen wir mal in die
Bewertung rein super Burger frisch und
schön angerichtete knusprige Fritten ich
bin gekommen da ich den Imbiss den Frank
Rosin wieder auf Vordermann gebracht hat
testen wollte fazit sehr empfehlenswert
ich komme wieder also auch Frank Rosin
direkt in der ersten Bewertung wieder zu
finden
meine schlechte Bewertung durch vor
einem Jahr ist die letzte ein Sterne
Bewertung scheinbar hat man hier
hauptsächlich daran gearbeitet wie man
Bewertungen löscht darum poste ich auch
ein drittes Mal das Essen ist weiterhin
ungenießbar ich glaube man kann gar
keine Bewertung löschen sondern muss mit
Anleitung vorgehen die Spezialität des
Hauses der Sauerbraten aus der
Mikrowelle ca 300 Grad warm war genauso
ungenießbar die nach alten Fett
schmeckenden noch ca 20 Grad warm
negative Bewertung sind auf jeden Fall
eher selten ich denke wir sollten uns
selbst auf den Weg machen und uns ein
Bild machen wie es dort heute nach drei
Jahren aussieht Rosins Restaurants hier
ist es ganz eindeutig Frank Rosin war
hier und hat Nickys Imbiss vermeintlich
geholfen wir gucken uns heute mal an was
ist übrig geblieben von dem was Frank
Rosinen hier eingeführt hat ist das
Essen und vor allem was ist danach
passiert wir lassen uns alles erzählen
aber gucken wir uns erstmal hier draußen
rum
ich sehe hier vorne schon das Schild
dass der gute Frank installiert hat
Frank und ich so das wurde in der Show
installiert als Straßenwerbung absolut
richtig hier läuft die Straße entlang
ihr hört es ihr seht es ist auf jeden
Fall einiges gut gelaufen aber nicht
alles nächster Blick gilt der Terrasse
hier draußen und man sieht jeder die
alten Terrassenmöbel hier draußen da gab
es auf jeden Fall schon mal eine
Änderung wieder rückgängig gemacht wurde
kleiner fun fact jetzt gerade stehe ich
in Belgien und wenn ich auf die andere
Straßenseite rübergehe bin ich schon in
Deutschland das heißt ich war heute im
Ausland hier vorne einmal schauen rechts
vom Laden der Verschlag ist da man sieht
nicht mehr die Mülltonnen das war
wichtig das ist richtig haben wir von
außen eine absolut solide Frittenbude
während wir hier draußen gerade gefilmt
haben seit 6 Minuten ist der Laden auf
sind schon zwei Kunden da gewesen also
ja und jetzt gucken wir mal wie es drin
aussieht
[Musik]
was erwartet hier in einem Restaurant
was gibt es hier in deinem Imbiss was
ist vielleicht neu dazu gekommen was es
geblieben für uns gerne mal durch also
von der rosinengeschichte wir sind hier
in den belgischen Imbiss ne wir sind
natürlich spezialisiert auf die
belgischen Schritte das heißt jetzt
sämtlichen Snack sieht dazu gehören
fertig Soßen und alles mögliche aber
bieten wir auch dazu an das heißt wir
haben frische Gerichte regionales
Fleisch was wir verarbeiten hier innen
drin räumlich verändert
natürlich hier anders aus jetzt nach dem
Rosinen kam neu Anstrich der kamen die
neuen Bilder da kann das nur Motor
Immobilie ja ich finde es wirklich gut
also eine sehr schönsten oder schöneren
dritten wurden in den ich auch danke
danke wir probieren jetzt erstmal das
Essen und dann danach
wollten und wir können das ein bisschen
tabakmäßig machen okay
[Musik]
wir haben alles bestellt was auch in der
Sendung eine Rolle gespielt hat wir
haben einen Burger wir haben das
Schnitzel das auch nicht nur gute Worte
abbekommen hat und natürlich die
belgischen Fritten dazu noch das
Tageslicht der Backfisch und so können
wir uns auf jeden Fall ein weites Bild
darüber fassen wie es wirklich ist und
danach quatschen wir mit Nicki wie das
ganze bei der Sendung lief und was
danach passiert ist
[Musik]
also Leute ich muss euch ganz ehrlich
sagen das essen was sich hier vor mir da
bietet ist einfach hübsch wir haben
knusprige belgische Fritten wir haben
Backfisch ein selbstgemachten Burger den
man eindeutig ansieht dass er selbst
gemacht ist wir haben Gulasch wir haben
Schaschlik und ein Schnitzel Wiener Art
also nichts an diesem Essen erinnert
daran dass das Restaurant jemals
gerettet werden musste weil es einfach
gut aussieht ich glaube das Wichtigste
von allem testen wir zuallererst sorry
übrigens für den Hai das liegt daran
dass das hier so eine große Halle ist
belgische Schritte so Samurai so eine
Schafe Mario Soße
schön knusprig also wenn sie eins nicht
tun dann alt schmecken oder das war ein
Kritikpunkt in der Serie findet
Belgische Pommes können nicht zu
knusprig sein also sie können fast noch
eine Ecke knuspriger sein für mich auf
jeden Fall auch besser als du die
klassische Pommes die du vielleicht dann
irgendeinem Meilen Restaurant bekommst
also die Pommes lassen wenig Wünsche
übrig sind wirklich ich habe Pommes
gesagt die Fritten lassen wenig Wünsche
übrig die sind wirklich gut und machen
wir weiter mit dem Burger gucken wir uns
zu allererst einmal das bannen an ist es
hier verbrannt nein es hat einen schönen
Crunch bekommen wir haben wirklich eine
ausgefallene Kreation mit frittiertem
Rucola Mozzarella Käse unten ordentlich
Soße so wie sie es gehört wie so ein
richtigen
frittenbudenburger 100% Homepage mit
frischem Hackfleisch haben wir auch
gesehen haben wir gezeigt bekommen
ihr wisst ja selbst der König der Bürger
ist für mich persönlich ein Smash Burger
hauchdünn knusprig trotzdem saftig aber
auch ein solcher Burger hat wirklich was
zu bieten durch diese gewisse Dicke 200
Gramm Fleisch sind auch meint er hat man
einfach so eine Saftigkeit und viel mehr
Textur im Mund auf jeden Fall also auch
noch ein bisschen Medium vielleicht ein
bisschen auch in der Folge tot gebraten
auf jeden Fall nicht mehr die Kreation
mit dem Pest und mit Rucola schmeckt
richtig frisch und richtig lecker da
muss auch mal probieren ist auch nichts
was man Imbiss findet der normale
Hamburger kostet 8 € was 30 auch
wirklich fair ist mehr wir sind hier
nicht in Köln wir sind nicht in der
Großstadt aber
das brauche ich nicht verstecken das
Teil ne richtig gut geil Pommes gut
Burger gut was noch kritisiert wurde als
tot frittiert aber das schnitzelt sieht
auf diesem schwarzen Geschirr auch
wirklich gut aus das Geschirr ist
übrigens nicht mehr das was ist bei
Frank Rosinen in der Sendung ab und das
hat auch guten Grund das erzählt aber
gleich bisschen Zitrone dran geh mal
rein schneidet sich tatsächlich nicht so
wahnsinnig einfach
ja verstecken einfach keine Schneider
mehr
Schnitte nicht persönlicher ab als die
anderen beiden Sachen es ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen zäher aber geil gewürzt
weiter geht's mit unserem Backfisch der
wurde gerade eben noch frisch
reingetragen vom Einkaufen ist ein
richtiger Alter
man schmeckt die frische vom Fisch Fisch
ist schön glasig knusprige Panade außen
rum und vor allen Dingen es wird hier
halt auch frisch gekocht ja Fisch gibt
es alle zwei Wochen freitags auch nur
ganz bewusst dass man wirklich dann wenn
man ihn anbietet in ganz frisch anbieten
kann und das sind halt auch so Dinge die
dazu kommen die aber auch Frank Rosin
angeregt hat ne frische Tagesgerichte
die frisches Tagesgericht haben wir hier
in Amsterdam hatten wir z.B diesen
killing der hat so laut knuspert man
wird schon fast so richtig laut
gekrachtet einfach nie gegessen hat und
kann finde ich eine Frittenbude nicht
mit dem Besten der Besten messen so und
was man hier bekommt reicht mehr als aus
das ist gut Schaschlik auf Tageslicht
schönen Paprika
[Musik]
Schmorgericht ne klassisches alter
Schwede boah schöne Paprika Note in der
Soße auch ordentlich süß die Soße hat
auch ein bisschen Imbiss Charakter und
das Gulasch
super zart superweich hier wieder eher
auf der süßen Seite beides vielleicht
ein Theken zu süß für mich bewegen uns
qualitativ wirklich auf einen sehr guten
Level so das ist kein Imbiss essen ja
selbst paniert frisch gemacht das Essen
ist wirklich gut das wissen wir jetzt
aber was hat Frank Rosin dazu
beigetragen reden wir jetzt mit Niki
darüber
Nicki wirklich Komplimente fürs Essen
also mehr als gedacht hätte wirklich
eine dritten Bude Hammer super ich habe
eine Frage würdest du ohne Frank Rosinen
heute noch hier stehen nein sehr
wahrscheinlich nein wow muss ich ehrlich
sagen also ich bin in Frank Rosinen
dankbar definitiv für die Werbung die
uns gebracht hat ohne diesen Werbeeffekt
ohne diese Unterstützung wäre ich denke
ich nicht mehr jung also da an der
Stelle kann man nur applaudieren für
Frank Rosin weil ich finde das super was
du hier machst und dass das ist dich
durch ihn wegen ihm noch gibt ja schon
mal mehr als alles andere wie viel
würdest du sagen hat dir das ganze
abseits des werbe-effekts gebracht also
ich will nicht unverständlich wirklich
gesagt ich bin wirklich dankbar für die
Sache die Fehler gemacht worden ist und
was es halt gebracht hat im Großen und
Ganzen habe ich mir schon mehr auch oft
eigentlich dass auf die Thematik der
dritte eingegangen wird dass mir als
Koch auch mal vielleicht ein paar Tipps
und Tricks gezeigt wird wie der Ablauf
vielleicht vereinfacht werden kann das
hat mir so ein bisschen gefehlt bekommen
ich habe gesehen Du hast es aber nicht
mehr da nein also ich muss ehrlich sagen
das Geschirr was wir von Frank Rosinen
bekommen habt ist wirklich meiner
Meinung nach aber auch zu much für eine
Frittenbude ja also habe ich da bin ich
hingegangen auf andere Teller geholt
unabhängig davon dass wir eh nur 20
Teller bekommen hatten 20 € 20 Teller
bei wie viel Sitzplätzen bei aktuell
wieder abgesichert reicht nicht aus ich
lese darauf dass relativ viel für die
Kamera ist also man sagt 20 Teller
weniger Mobiliar das ist natürlich auch
verständlich das ist eine immer wieder
erscheinende Serie die wollen ihre
Stories haben wenn du das Gewichten so
wie viel Prozent sind Sie da um dir zu
helfen mit den Tipps hier vor Ort bei
der Werbe-Effekt natürlich massiv dazu
bei und wie viel Prozent ist Story
ist schon so dass das Team Frank Rosinen
schon die Problematik annimmt die wir
wieder da ist das hatten wir ja gesagt
mit meiner Familie auch wieder das Klima
gehabt aber es ist schon
Unterhaltungssendung aber noch mal ich
möchte wirklich betonen ich bin den
ganzen dankbar weil halt werden Effekt
sehr gepusht hat und damit auch geholfen
hat ne von daher will ich keine
umgangbarkeit zeigen deine Sache bleibt
gleich dass du auch zum Eingang meintest
würdest heute nicht mehr hier stehen
deshalb können glaube ich alle
Beteiligten dankbar sein dass du bei der
Show mitgemacht hast super mach weiter
so ich hoffe wir sehen uns noch mal
wieder in 1 2 Jahren vielleicht kommen
wir an der Cover wieder vorbei so wie
kabel eins auch das war voll ne also
gerettet das Restaurant eine Sache
möchte ich dazu noch sagen denn wir
haben auch mit ein zwei Restaurants
telefoniert bei denen es nicht ganz so
glimpflicht lief wie hier ich glaube
nicki ist auf jeden Fall ein positives
Beispiel das will ich zumindest der
Ferne Cyber erwähnen ich fand es nice
hier ich fand es spannend nicki ist ein
cooler Typ eine Sache muss man sagen
jemandem zu helfen und seine Situation
zu verbessern das ist natürlich eine
super Sache deswegen Freunde wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Video wieder macht's
gut bis dahin ciao